[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con desde esta
semana hemos venido haciendo seguimiento
a la reforma educativa que comenzó a
finales de 2015 en perú y que hoy deja
más de un tercio de las universidades
del país cerradas por falta de calidad
como argumenta el gobierno ya hemos
conversado con el titular de la
superintendencia nacional de educación
superior universitaria de perú y hoy lo
haremos con natalia matías egresada de
la universidad alas peruanas una de las
50 instituciones cerradas que no tenía
licencia de funcionamiento gracias
natalia por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 quiero empezar preguntando si
sabía que la universidad no contaba con
los requisitos y estándares exigidos por
las autoridades peruanas de educación
cuando decidió ingresar en ella
hola buenos días qué tal
cuando yo ingresé desde el primer
instante que ingresé la universidad
siempre
tenía fallas tenía carencias y siempre
estaba a la volada o siempre estaba en
salí de las noticias de que orar
probablemente se le lleva a denegar la
licencia miento
desde que yo entré que fue
aproximadamente en el 2013 ya estaba
esto y se podía notar en las
instalaciones de la universidad ahora
que no está vaya usted sabía que esa
universidad era mala usted se fue dando
que cuenta con el tiempo estudiando en
esa institución que no era lo que usted
esperaba
en claro era era un mal pero quizás no
catastrófica uno veía que había mejores
universidades pereció es bueno además en
la capacidad de pago de quizás de las de
los padres no era tanta como para
brindar una mejor educación
en la universidad uno no se daba cuenta
uno ha pasado por alto ciertas cosas
pero pero siempre había algo y con
algunos se daba cuenta lo que la
situación de otras facultades de la
misma universidad era muchísimo peor por
ejemplo demoraron demasiado en poner
bibliotecas demasiado demasiado tiempo
en adaptar sondas para los estudiantes
que los mismos estudiantes lograron
probar correctivas y construir un techo
donde trabajar
en el cip natalia usted logró terminar
sus estudios en esa universidad que está
haciendo ahora o que va a hacer
claro yo acabé en el 2019 ciclo 1
ese año acabe y comencé mis trámites
para sacar el título de egresado me tomo
tiempo debido a que los trámites son
engorrosos justo ayer encontré unos
papeles donde me pedían 10 requisitos
para sacar mi título de egresada por
cada requisito yo tenía que comprar una
solicitud y la solicitud dejarla a una
oficina diferente en diferentes locales
en donde estas locales estaban lejos y
no tenían comunicación de información de
la otra me demoro tiempo en sacar mis
papeles sumado a que no tenían un
registro de los datos de los alumnos y
por ende hubo un problema con mi dni
desinformación y cuando yo tengo mis
papeles a la semana un 25 24 de
diciembre dicen que la universidad es
tierra y yo tenía mi folder listo para
entregar que hacía
yo tenía la oportunidad de como aún no
había entregado mis papeles para sacar
mi bachiller ir a otra universidad a
terminar mi décimo ciclo cuando fui a
otra universidad con licencia en
funcionamiento con una nueva malla
curricular porque yo es pertenecía de la
antigua maya y todas las universidades a
las que íbamos a las que preguntábamos
tenía nueva maya
entonces cuando me con la sorpresa de
que yo no podía convalidar un curso o
dos cursos sino que iba a convalidar
casi dos años de carrera y que
automáticamente me iban a pasar a una
nueva malla con nuevos cursos en donde
yo ya no salía quizás con título de
egresada si no me iba a tomar dos doble
doble trabajo doble año sacar el título
si por sitio de por cien mi mente es la
darme de una universidad denegada con mi
maya cómic syllabus y la busqué hasta el
momento los alumnos no pueden sacar los
alumnos que aún están en la universidad
yo fue con este si le gusta otra
universidad y me dijeron no universidad
no está compatibilizada son mis pollos
de esta casa de estudios y te tomaría
como dos años muy además de pote fina
hipótesis lamentable lamentable natalia
la situación que ustedes como estudiante
estudiantes y universidades peruanos
tienen que enfrentar esperemos que se
pueda resolver pronto esta situación
muchísimas gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en cinco minutos
con en france24 también ustedes gracias
por estar siempre ahí en nuestra
pantalla
[Música]